.
- J'ai déjà été affilié à
Chomedey 45, mais je me suis
fait poignarder par, genre,
par du monde qui sont affiliés
à ces g- Bruce est un survivante
la rue qui est à peine majeur.
Victime de tentative de meurtre
et de menaces de mort durant
il sort de prison pour
une affaire de stupéfiants.
En parlant de son vécu, il p des
de rue pour des jeunes de
quartiers défavorisés.
du monde-là, 15 000 $ la tête.
Des affaires de... "Tu tires
chez eux, 1500."
- C'est du cash, pareil,
quand t'as 16 ans ou 15 ans ou
13 ans.
ces jeunes doivent s'attendre
à faire face à la justice
à la place des vétérans
de la rue qui donnent l'ordre
- C'est pas juste de l'argent.
Des fois, le jeune, c'est
juste... comment je peux
dire ça? Pour le "fame". Eux,
en sachant que les grands du
quartier les respe
les peines imposées aux mineurs
et aux adultes pour les mêmes
crimes. C'est une sorte de
purgatoire pour gagner le
- Et cette culture de
la violefuse dans
les écoles secondaires de Laval.
Selon nos informations,
la présence de couteaux est
un fléau dans certaines écoles
res.
- Au début de l'année,
je voulais pas aller à l'école.
Pour cause que, à l'école il y a
toujours des jeunes qui sont
impliqués dans les gangs de rue.
- Dans son esprit, Françoise,
encore adolescente, dit avoir
senti la nécessité de s'armerpa.
- Ton couteau, tu le trainais
où? Dans ton sac d'école?
Dans tes vêtements? Tu le tenais
proche au cas où?
- Je le gardais dans
ma saccoche.
- L'adolescente esment
consciente qu'elle risquait
une détention en Centre jeunesse
si elle se faisait prendre
avec une arme.
- Les gens prennent plus
leur sécurité que leur liberté.
Ils choisissent leur sécurité.
Honnêtement, j'avais pas peur
de me faire prendre avec.
J'avais plus peur de
ne pas savoir l'utiliser.
- Françoise a grandi dans
un milieu où son entourage
s'est laissé séduire par
l'argent et la reconnaissance
s de rue.
- Pour n'importe qui, parce que
déjà, un, tu fais de l'argent
sale, et quand c'est de l'argent
tu fais, t'as pas
vraiment fait trop d'efforts
pour l'avoir donc t'as tendance
à vite le gaspiller.
Ce qui fait que tu as tendance
à vouloir en refaire plus et
tout le temps plus, et à prendre
de plus gros risques.
ce qui peut, à l
te faire tomber.
- Dans la rue, les problèmes
se règlent dans la rue.
Gare àmertà
pour parler avec toute forme
d'autorité.
- La haine contre ceux qui osent
briser le silence est bien
ancrée dans la culture de
violence chez les jeunes.
MICHAEL GOUIN, int
Mesures alternatives jeunesse
- Ils idéalisent des gens qui
parlent contre les "snitchs",
donc ils vont faire en sorte
de ne pa
dans cette catégorie-là.
C'est beaucoup la mentalité
un petit peu qu'il y a dans
les chansons les films puis
sés, qu'on
voit, du crime organisé.
- Après des années à flirter
avec la violence, Bruce esttouje
inciter des jeunes à sortir
du cercle vicieux de la violence
de la rue.
- À l'instar de Bruce, Françoise
elle aussi veut une vie loin de
la violence de la rue.
- C'est rendu que ça fait
partie de mon quotidien.
Mais j'ai réalisé que c'est pas
vraiment ça, une vraie vie.
Tu peux pas toujours vivre
en état de stress.'a qu'un objef
en tête.
- Je voudrais devenir
intervenante.
Finir mes études.
- Ici Pascal Robidas,
Radio-Canada, Mo